[Musique]
et cette invité aujourd'hui c'est vous
Nicolas Floch bonjour bonjour bienvenue
sur ce plateau plasticien photographe
plongeur lanceur d'alerte comme comment
faut-il vous présenter
Nicolas Floch à Paris photos qui ouvre
ses portes ce jeudi au public au Grand
Palais éphémère sur le Champ de Mars ici
à Paris photos c'est une foire
internationale qui a lieu tous les ans
qu'un rendez-vous important et qui met
particulièrement cette année votre
travail en valeur avec ce qu'on appelle
un solo show ce travail on le découvre
ensemble à l'antenne vous nous emmener à
Nicolas Floch à la découverte d'un monde
que l'on connaît peu et qui nous est
pourtant vital on va y revenir c'est le
monde sous-marin il vous est familier
depuis votre enfance bretonne vous êtes
un plongeur passionné qu'est-ce qui vous
a donné envie d'en faire un objet
artistique
je pense d'abord le fait que qu'on peu
de gens voient cet environnement c'est à
dire c'est il est absolument central
puisque on dépend complètement de cette
océan qui couvre 70% de la surface de la
Terre mais quand on pense au volume
d'habitat disponible pour le vivant
c'est 97% donc c'est vraiment quelque
chose de deux je dirais de d'absolument
essentiel et on a des images de cet
océan mais qui sont
souvent
stéréotypé je dirais et souvent les
mêmes images qui reviennent et je pense
que il est important peut-être de
montrer aussi un peu différemment
l'océan et de
[Musique]
déjà de montrer tout simplement ce qu'on
voit quand on passe sous la surface
alors pour ce faire vous plongez avec
votre appareil photo soit en apnée soit
en bouteille principalement le long des
côtes françaises mais pas que et les
paysages effectivement absolument que
vous nous faites découvrir sont
absolument stupéfiants on est à 10 20 30
mètres sous la surface de l'eau on
pourrait être parfois en oublie bien sûr
qu'il y a de l'eau on pourrait être tout
à fait ailleurs
oui alors le choix justement du noir et
blanc permet de peut-être d'évacuer un
certain exotisme et de rentrer dans un
ailleurs de dans un espace un petit peu
indéfini que l'on
pourrait je dirais habiter si on ne
l'habitait pas déjà puisqu'on habite
quelque part indirectement cet océan et
et le noir et blanc nous emmène par
exemple si on pense aux forêts de de
laminaire en Bretagne on pourrait être
dans une jungle d'une autre planète ou
une jungle inconnue si on pense aux
grands fonds aux photos des grands fonds
on pourrait être littéralement sur une
autre planète
on a l'impression que c'est un petit peu
marre sous la lune mais c'est bourré de
vivant partout c'est à dire mais un
vivant microscopique pas quelque chose
de de spectaculaire c'est à dire que le
l'essentiel du vivant dans le Séan il
est il est pas directement visible c'est
à dire qu'on peut le
de lire par exemple dans la couleur de
l'eau
la couleur de l'eau va nous donner une
indication sur le vivant qui se trouve
dans une masse d'eau dans la colonne
d'eau mais la couleur de l'eau qui est
le nom aussi d'un autre projet qui vous
faites qui nous emmène là pour le coup
loin du noir et blanc mais qui nous
ramène à la fragilité de l'océan
peut-être vous pouvez nous en dire
quelques mots à la fragilité et aux
paysages géré le plus commun puisque
dans le enfin l'image la plus commune
dans l'océan serait une image noire
puisque la profondeur moyenne c'est 3800
mètres dans l'océan et la zone qu'on
appelle la zone fautique la zone où il y
a de la lumière c'est à peu près les 200
premiers mètres donc dans ces
200 premiers mètres ce qu'on va voir
quand on rentre dans l'eau c'est
principalement de la couleur alors si on
est loin au Larche avec du bleu si on
est sur des zones côtières cette couleur
va être plutôt être du vert qui va être
dû ou phytoplancton c'est à dire au
micro-algue qui se trouve dans les
masses d'eau et qui sont à la base du
vivant dans l'océan enfin de la chaîne
ce qu'on appelle la chaîne trophique la
chaîne alimentaire et
ensuite quand on remonte dans les
estuaires ou vers les fleuves là on a
toutes les matières qui viennent de la
terre c'est-à-dire les matières
organiques dissoute les minéraux tous
les végétaux les tanins des végétaux qui
vont
donner des couleurs beaucoup plus
chaudes et donc on a en fait on remonte
comme ça mais ce qui est ce qui est
absolument fabuleux c'est qu'on le
remonte géographiquement le on a le
cercle chromatique la décomposition du
du de des couleurs en fait parce qu'on
retrouve des rouges des oranges des
jaunes et quand on voit l'organisation
par exemple dans un fleuve puisque en
fait la terre vient nourrir la mer quand
le cette terre qui est tous ces
sédiments qui sont portés par les
fleuves quand ils arrivent dans l'océan
ils vont nourrir ce vivant ils vont
nourrir ces micro-algues et et la
couleur va changer mais
par exemple une des
une
prise de vue que j'ai fait dans le
Mississippi sur 100 km parce qu'il faut
en fait quand je fais des prises de vue
dans la colonne d'eau c'est un peu comme
un carottage dans un sol c'est à dire
ce sont des photos prises en face de moi
différentes profondeurs
alors dans le bleu on va être sur sur ça
en mètres
dans parce que je suis cette zone où il
y a de la lumière dans un fleuve la
lumière va beaucoup moins profond donc
ça va être sur quelques mètres mais je
prends des photos donc tous les 10 15 cm
dans un fleuve tous les 10 mètres par
exemple dans l'océan et on va avoir
comme ça une coupe dans la masse d'eau
et cette coupe si on prend le cas du
Mississippi par exemple où j'ai le c'est
là que j'ai le plus de couleurs sur 100
km on a quasiment tout le spectre ce
qu'on va retrouver dans la toute
concurrentielle toutes les couleurs
mais ce qui est fabuleux c'est que c'est
une organisation
géographique et c'est ça n'est pas juste
une décomposition de la lumière c'est à
dire c'est c'est sous l'eau on a cette
quasiment cet arc-en-ciel qui apparaît
alors ça nous ramène à l'autre casquette
si j'ose dire que vous avez parce que
vous collaborez aussi avec des
scientifiques et ce projet la couleur de
l'eau s'inscrit dans cette démarche là
votre intention et que votre travail
servent aussi à illustrer le péril que
vit l'océan aujourd'hui et ça nous
ramène au sujet du jour la COP 27 et
vous avez vous qui plongez quasiment
depuis toujours été le témoin en
quelques années du changement de ces
fonds sous-marins
oui alors j'ai j'ai décidé de en fait de
travailler sur un sur une sorte
d'inventaire en fait des paysages des
côtes françaises enfin de la France
métropolitaine
et parce que déjà comme je disais ces
paysages on ne les connais pas on ne les
voit pas donc c'était faire émerger ces
paysages mais aussi montrer un état des
paysages à un moment donné puisque ces
paysages se transforment très vite il y
a des glissements d'écosystèmes dans
l'océan qui sont 6 fois plus rapides que
sur terre
et donc
ces paysages dans 10 ans dans 15 ans
dans 20 ans se feront plus les mêmes et
toutes mes prises de vue sont des prises
de vue panoramiques donc c'est vraiment
quand on passe la surface de l'eau c'est
ce qui s'étend sous le regard et
il me paraissait important de d'avoir
une trace de ces paysages parce que
étonnamment on n'a pas de photo et on se
rend compte quand on voit les images on
se rend compte qu'on les connaît pas et
vous dites qu'à l'échelle d'un bout de
vie vous avez vu ces paysages
sous-marins passez vous parliez de la
forêt bretonne tout à l'heure de forêt à
des Landes complètement désertées sous
l'action quoi du réchauffement d'eau de
l'acidification de l'eau c'est-à-dire
Louis il y a le réchauffement
alors l'acidification c'est un processus
qui est plus lent mais qui affecte
l'ensemble des autres et je dirais aussi
le les rejets directs en fait
alors par exemple j'ai fait une série à
Marseille qui s'appelle invisible où
j'ai longer ensemble du trait de côte du
parc des Calanques où j'ai pris
quasiment une photo tous les tous les 10
mètres le long de ces 162 km et on voit
sur cette zone comment le paysage se
transforme il y a en plein cœur du parc
des Calanques qui a le rejet des eaux
usées de la ville de Marseille une
petite un petit cours d'eau qui a été
qui a été détourné et on voit cet
endroit là que les paysages sont il y a
aucune vie fixée il y a on a énormément
de de phytoplancton qui se développent
dans les masses d'eau puisqu'il y a un
dérèglement du haut rejet mais on a on a
plus de vie fixé dans le paysage on peut
lire la transformation
due à des rejets d'origine anthropique
mais ce phénomène qui est très lisible
dans un endroit comme le parc des
Calanques c'est un phénomène qui existe
partout puisque si on prend Paris par
exemple Paris le le canal de
d'évacuation on va dire c'est la scène
et ça va être ça va être la manche alors
que faut-il le rappeler et c'est
là-dedans aussi que va s'inscrit votre
travail la mer l'océan fait partie d'un
tout et c'est dans ce tout que vous
remettez aussi ces photos là si nous
respirons c'est grâce à l'océan
le vrai poumon de la planète c'est c'est
l'océan c'est à dire il y a plus de la
moitié de l'oxygène qui est produite
des produits par l'océan et quand on
parle par exemple de cette de cette
couleur ce qui est ce qui est assez
fascinant avec la couleur de l'eau c'est
qu'à partir de la couleur on peut lire
énormément de choses et par exemple cet
échange
l'absorption du du
CO2 par l'océan
la production d'oxygène elle va être
lisible en partie par la couleur c'est à
dire une eau verte et une eau qui
produit de l'oxygène une eau qui fixe du
carbone alors après ça peut être un
indicateur aussi dérèglement comme ce
qu'on appelle des
sur des zones comme dans le dans la baie
du
dans le coffre du Mexique où on a tous
les apports du Mississippi on a vu la
carte tout à l'heure du Mississippi du
bassin versant du Mississippi ce qui est
un fleuve c'est pas une ligne qui part
de la source jusqu'à l'embouchure c'est
tout un réseau hydrographique et c'est
tout le ruissellement de tout ce
territoire qui termine dans à
l'embouchure est-ce que ces changements
que vous constatez dans les océans c'est
pour ceci c'est trop tard c'est
irrévocable ou est-ce que la vie les
paysages peuvent-être d'une façon ou
d'une autre alors il y a je dirais qu'il
y a une
les choses se peuvent se régénérer très
vite
on voit que dès que dès qu'on a une
dépression qui diminue les choses se
transforme rapidement cependant
on a des phénomènes globaux et les
décisions par exemple qui seront prises
par les gouvernements et les dans les
années à venir seront absolument
déterminants parlé mais vous travaillez
aussi sur les habitats artificiels que
l'homme remet dans la mer d'une certaine
façon pour réparer ses bêtises et vous
avez beaucoup voilà on voit quelques
photos de ça c'est comme ça que j'ai
commencé à travailler en fait vraiment
sur le milieu sous-marin j'ai toujours
travaillé sur l'océan mais en
m'intéressant à ses habitats artificiels
qui m'ont amené ensuite à travailler sur
des habitats naturels ces habitats
artificiels sont faits effectivement
pour régénérer des biotopes
un plaidoyer artistique et écologique
donc merci beaucoup Nicolas flaque oui
juste je voulais peut-être citer déjà la
galerie Maubert avec qui je travaille à
Paris photos et aussi les gens qui
m'accompagnent il y a reconnexion à
Lille la fondation camargot à Cassis qui
m'accompagne sur les productions des
projets qui sont assez lourdes et pas
mal de partenaires scientifiques comme
Ifremer
votre appareil photo sur des sous-marins
qui descendent là très très loin
merci beaucoup qui soit remercier ici
merci beaucoup d'être venu sur le
plateau de Paris direct on peut
retrouver donc vos photos à Paris Photo
à partir de jeudi on l'a dit au Grand
Palais FMR sur le Champ de Mars ici à
Paris merci encore la suite du journal
tout de suite c'est avec Damien coquet
on retourne sur Terre à tout de suite
[Musique]